hey guys it's Joe and Andy from honest
trailers and we have a treat for you
another roast this time the roast of
Dolph beta seems right now it's not
really important who left who to die as
a triple amputee in an active volcano
let's just stay focused on the roast
[Music]
it's going to be an uphill
oops freezing this is just friendly
burns Sorry Sorry
I was going to make a dead Padme joke
but I want to maintain the hard ground
and that would have been going Mustafar
much much too fun so I will pose by
honoring Darth Vader with a quote from
the man himself
[Music]
they say girls want a guy that reminds
them of their dad that's why I've been
using my vibrator so much it is big
black mechanical and it has to choke me
to finish the job fell in love with Leia
Organa the moment I laid eyes on her I
was excited because I heard she likes
making out with brothers but then I
realized she meant literally you guys
burn when she warned that metal bikini
at Jabba's palace dick got down tell me
on Beru because I blew milk that was a
joke but the people who really liked
Star Wars so I better explain that one
to George Lucas and now lord Vader
himself a tough black exterior with a
soft weak white man inside are you not a
sip your drink jokes I was 10
sometimes punchline comes set before it
does barely understand myself I do
knock-knock jokes impossible they are do
or do not there is no try
unless a nerve defending the prequels
you are then you try all the time you
might think I'm lame but from my point
of view I'm totally sick
seriously you guys think I suck you guys
is this a stageful to Jared Leto's cuz
you guys are the best Jokers I have ever
seen I'm a grown man you hear that
obi-wan I've got the high ground now me
you dick I turned you in the laundry and
I didn't even pick it up plus all the
Jedi now suck I used to do hella flips
and ninja stuff Luke one question do you
even flip bro Luke are you sure you
didn't pork your sister that kylo Ren of
hers feels like he's missing a
midi-chlorian or two I suppose I can
only blame myself for your taste in men
but still you married a space pirate if
you really wanted to get back at me you
could just put sand in my ventilator I
don't like sand it's coarse and rough
and irritating and gets everywhere
shut up youngmee you failed me for the
last time this sad display is exactly
why I watch Star Trek live long and
prosper nerds which one of those jokes
was the most cringe to you and which
audience members sounded the fakest let
us know in the comments guys if you want
to watch the entire roast go to screen
junkies com sign up with your Facebook
that's right and if you actually want to
attend one of these roasts in person
that's right real people actually watch
this and actually last you can do so by
coming over in January to Los Angeles
and attend a future taping make it so
welcome to Jurassic Park